what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a really awesome
report that is finally linking to the
origin of the X-Men in the MCU and it is
kind of tying back to the eternals in
the MCU which is really cool because in
the comics the origin of the X-Men are
directly related to the origin of the
eternals now we thought they kind of
changed this in the MCU and they did
however it does look like the celestial
still could be responsible for creating
the X-Men mutants and the mutant Gene
and it looks like the first big dive
into the X-Men world and their origin
story could be taking place in the
Thunderbolts film so today we have some
pretty big plot points about the
Thunderbolts film including how it could
directly connect to the home of the
mutants inside the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so a lot to dive into today
also some more news about Sentry in the
Thunderbolts film and his entry into the
MCU we'll break it down in this video
and also big reminder we're still doing
our Marvel Legends giveaway all you have
to do to enter subscribe to the channel
and leave a comment down below the
winner will be announced in a video and
we're going to continue the giveaways
into the next year so lots of giveaways
to come so be sure to subscribe so
today's report makes the Thunderbolts
movie very very interesting even more
interesting than it was before like I
mentioned we do have some more news
about Sentry but first let's talk about
how the Thunderbolts movie is going to
connect to the X-Men specifically a huge
connection to Wolverine according to a
report from Insider Daniel rpk tayamat
which is the dreaming Celestial from the
eternals film the one that Cersei froze
at the very end has been transformed
into the island ganosha and this is huge
and if you don't know why it's huge
don't worry I'll explain but this
explains why we haven't really heard
anything about tayamat since the
internals this is actually a question a
lot of fans have been asking every
single MCU project that we've gotten so
far be it a movie or show why hasn't
anybody mentioned the huge Celestial
sticking out of the middle of the ocean
that is just setting there it's a good
question to ask and it looks like Marvel
Studios was planning on addressing this
after all and while I don't really see
how they could have ignored this but
tayamat is actually going to serve as
gnosha the home of the mutants in Marvel
Comics now before we dive into that a
little bit more let's talk about why
they're going to go there the second
half of the report states that the
Thunderbolts will venture to the island
in their film in search of adamantium
now if you're not aware adamantium is
the metal that is inside of Wolverine
it's what his claws are made out of and
it laces his entire skeleton now this
leads me to believe that a celestial's
body could be made entirely out of
adamantium if not at least some of it
otherwise why would the Thunderbolts be
going to Kenosha which again according
to this report is the head or maybe the
full body if it's hollowed out of
tayamat I'm assuming that this is
somewhat going to be like nowhere we
know that nowhere is the decapitated
head of a celestion and people made a
whole city out of the inside of it in
fact the Guardians of the Galaxy now
owned that City so I'm assuming ganosha
is going to be somewhat similar I'm
assuming that people are going to be
mining certain materials inside of
taimut's head one of them being
adamantium perhaps the whole outside of
a celestial's body the skin if you will
is made of adamantium and if you think
about it when we take a look at nowhere
the skull basically does seem to be
stripped of whatever material consists
of its skin so perhaps it's been
stripped of its adamantium and there's a
lot of adamantium out there in the
universe somewhere but now we have a
whole entire new Celestial whose entire
body for the most part is accessible and
probably covered in adamantium and this
explains why the Thunderbolts are going
there because of course Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine and Thunderbolt Ross
the US government I should add some
corrupt people in the US government want
adamantium for themselves of course and
in fact this could lead up to the
creation of Wolverine in fact it
wouldn't surprise me one bit if
Thunderbolt Ross hadn't already created
The Weapon X pro program after all that
just kind of makes perfect sense we know
Thunderbolt Ross has been after the
perfect super soldier serum and now that
Harrison Ford is playing Thunderbolt
Ross they clearly have bigger plans for
him in the MCU and I won't be surprised
if his bigger plans are the weapon x
program this could be why the
Thunderbolts are going to tiemut for
Thunderbolt Ross and this could lead us
to the origin of Wolverine in the MCU
yes Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is coming
back in Deadpool 3 and yes it is going
to be fantastic and if the rumors are
true some of the old Fox X-Men are going
to be appearing in the MCU and Secret
Wars as well which I am super excited
for however eventually and possibly very
soon since the Thunderbolts are looking
for adamantium eventually new X-Men
characters and New Mutants are going to
have to enter the MCU and I'm thinking
that that's exactly why the Thunderbolts
are heading to taima to get adamentium
to give to their government and the
reason the Thunderbolts are going there
is because tiamat's head is most likely
going to be like nowhere it's going to
be filled with a lot of different people
a lot of them being criminals I'm
assuming this place is going to kind of
run itself no government really involved
now this is very different from gnosha
in the comics in fact ganosha in the
comics has a pretty rough backstory the
British took it over in the 18th century
then in the 1900s it became its own
State however they enslaved mutants and
they kind of figured out a way to
brainwash mutants and use their powers
for specific labor purposes now
eventually Magneto would be super pissed
off about this obviously and he would
basically take control later on
Professor Xavier goes there as well to
try and help him So eventually down the
road it kind of becomes somewhat of a
refuge for mutants so as you can see
here it's going to be very different
however it is still apparently going to
be titled gnosha which means that some
people inside could be mutants people
with superpowers people with the X Gene
so we could be getting our very first
look at the mutants in the MCU new ones
not like Miss Marvel retconned into a
mutant or Namor which we already knew
but I'm talking about brand new
characters who are mutants in the MCU so
I'm super excited about that and let me
know what you think about that in the
comments down below but we still have
some awesome Sentry news to talk about
in this video but first big thank you to
Mint mobile for sponsoring this video in
this video most people know about mint
mobile because of Ryan Reynolds but most
people don't know about mint Mobile's
amazing quality now I live in the
mountains and service isn't too good
however mint mobile sent me a free plan
and I get better service with their plan
than I do with my other provider but
what's crazy is their plan is so much
cheaper mint mobile offers Wireless for
just 15 bucks a month they give you the
best rate whether you're buying for one
or a family and at mint mobile families
start at only two lines all plans come
with unlimited talk and text plus high
speed data delivered on the nation's
largest 5G Network plus mint Mobile's
Modern Family Plan lets you mix and
match data plans so everyone gets the
amount of data that's right for them and
you can use your own phone and keep your
same number and contacts so to get your
new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a
month including the Modern Family Plan
go to mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
bill down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic so before we
basically knew that century was going to
be the villain of the Thunderbolts movie
but we didn't exactly know why now I
mentioned before that I wouldn't be
surprised if Thunderbolt Ross was
basically making a weapon x program
already and Century being in the movie
actually backs that up a little bit if
indeed Thunderbolt Ross and Valentina
created him that's actually some pretty
significant proof that our government is
working to actually enhance and
transform people into Super people so
I'm calling it right now the
Thunderbolts are going to get adamentium
and that's eventually going to make
Wolverine but back to Sentry in another
report from Insider Daniel rpk he says
that century will reportedly first
appear as a member of the Thunderbolts
team throughout the film he will start
hearing voices and lose his mind leaving
the Thunderbolts having to stop him at
all costs now for those of you who may
know a little bit about Century you're
probably thinking what I'm thinking the
void for those of you who don't know the
void was a giant shadowy monster that
killed over 1 million people in
Manhattan New York but what they would
eventually go on to discover was that
the void was actually the dark aspect of
the Century's own powers it turns out
the void was actually the Century's
repressed Persona and the only way that
they got rid of the Void was by wiping
the memory of Robert Reynolds AKA
Century of the Century superhero himself
ever existing in doing so the void went
away but when his memory came back to
him the void came back so when this
report says that the century hears a
voice inside of his head I'm thinking
that it's the void and the void might
actually show up at some point in time
during the Thunderbolts film so that is
how the century is apparently going to
become the villain of the Thunderbolts
movie now I'm assuming the century is
also going to become a good person at
some point in time and be a hero in the
comics he is a mentor to Spider-Man he's
a really good friend of Reed Richards
and the entire Fantastic Four also the
X-Men as well so I'm assuming Sentry at
one point in time is going to be good
however I am really excited to see him
as a part of the Thunderbolts team and
I'm excited to see where this movie
heads because it sounds like it's going
to have some pretty serious implications
moving forward in the MCU but hey let us
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below let me know what you
think about my Wolverine origin Theory
or if you have a theory of your own
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news and theories you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
foreign